do you think at any point of your life  you felt like you were socially awkward  I didn't find out until I moved to LA my  first time like being in the green room  as a comedian because it's like it's a  lot of pressure when you're when you're  a new comedian going into a green room  you're in a room with other comedians  you feel like you have to be funny  you're trying to like impress a little  bit and network at the same time Network  and just measuring dicks yep you know  with comedy though yeah oh that that  funny bone funny dicks funny boners  exactly you would do really bad in a  green room  why did I make it so real why can't we  just shoot the [ __ ] as homies here Why  Can't This Be Like A JK News Talk Show  where we just he wasn't even like yeah  about me would that be good  yeah that would uh that would [ __ ]  turn my boner down dude